I absolutely believe water is a human
right a basic human right for every
single person in this world
each of these slots is for electrodes to
going what we found is for now to
aluminum work really great and this is
another 3d printed printed lid for the
mason jar and we wanted to keep costs
low so that the parts that we use are
very inexpensive so the technology works
by running an electric current through
water and depending on what metals
you're using and what pollutants or
contaminants are in the water you can
sometimes separate those contaminants
with this current that's that's a
simplest way
I am actually not an electrician or an
engineer of any kind but what we've
decided to do is actually you know reach
out to maker spaces and universities
around the world
so in 10 years aleko will have a network
that reaches around the world and
everybody is able to go on to our
website look up what problem they're
having with water and get a recipe that
will help them solve that and it could
be with our technology the coagulator or
it could be with other open source
technologies want more on water check
out our running dry playlist